[Music]
what do you guys
know about mukbangs
they're delicious yeah it's delicious
it's korean it's korean
mukbang they get hella views oh it's
true why how come we don't do mukbangs
oh there we go it's not our format of
the show we try yeah we have
it yeah on patreon we we did it i like
that
and during the live stream we did it
yeah i mean it's not like we don't
really
do it do it you know because those guys
got mics so you can hear them
yeah and then they eat like gigantic
proportions that's true
it's crazy are they like the little
asian girls that have like the live
animals
oh yeah we covered that on this channel
right we uh we talked about one of the
garages
crazy like it's like the spices throws
on a live ass shrimp or lobster and
she's like
yeah you know those girls would get um
i think they would really get along with
the crazy white kids that go into the
forest and like
eat like animals raw and stuff like just
you know how they do that for shock
like those australian white kids that go
out and just like they fish and then
they cook it and then just eat it in the
wild with them no no that's a catch and
cook i'm talking about the more
jackassy types like they just grab a
[ __ ] cricket yeah and they go
yeah and i'm like hey that's a that's
kind of a match made in heaven dude
true true true why are you asking me
about luke banks
well there is a mukbang blogger who has
4.4 million followers
and she's being called out for cheating
by allegedly spitting out food oh i
didn't know there were rules to mukbangs
i thought it was just like oh you're
eating on camera and it was more about
like the sensations of
sounds and whatnot but apparently you
have to
eat food like seriously just eat food a
lot of people [ __ ] cheat
a lot of people cheat stephanie doesn't
though we all eat the food oh that's
good when we go to our house we just
[ __ ]
if i did a mukbang i would totally cheat
it's like i would [ __ ] be so [ __ ]
fat
if i had to eat all that food then why
does it have to be so big
like the proportions have to be so
gigantic i mean i don't know like who
said the rules
i don't know i think it's more cinematic
versus like like two like imagine a
white castle burger
versus like i got eight four by fours
for men and it just looks more cinematic
true and then it's like a longer video
because you're actually eating and
the whole process so this is uh bach
he and she has a channel where she eats
a
lot
of korean food and she is now
uh i don't know what she's eating here
it looks like vietnamese food
it does no this is like kimchi this
looks like kimchi fried rice
right here this is this is very
vietnamese oh that looks like vermicelli
yeah yeah
and this is the mom right here no
yeah maybe it's the korean fish sauce
yeah mukbang
it's not look mom it's mukbang
apparently uh mukbang uh purists
and i guess for all the purists it's
mukbang the mukbang
judges yes exactly they uh they the
hardcore
ones yes they are picking up a huge
sausage
they're picking apart her videos and
trying to figure out
why there are certain edits in the video
so apparently you're
if it's the one continuous take you
don't do any edits it's very authentic
obviously you're eating the food or
swallowing it what not
but for her she has random edits that
people are just they're like why
so for example she's eating and then as
she's
going for another bite you'll see that
crossfade oh slow motion
so as she she puts her finger up
for an edit yes and you felt you you you
caught that finger right so bring it up
what did she do damn you saw that what
is this some [ __ ]
sleight of hand she went like that she
does this real quick
finger and then moments later transition
edit right yeah so then what is that
what is that
is there crossfade on her body no it's
just her it's just the hand so her body
didn't move
what's the finger for interesting so
here's another example
i feel like we're catching a criminal in
action yes we are
here's another oh here's another example
come on play
finger again and what happens next cut
but why would she leave the finger then
if this is it this is her slating
it's like an edit note for her later
she's like the cover here bless you yeah
i
think
we're saying people are saying bless you
people are saying the finger up
is some sort of production code yeah if
she doesn't edit her own videos then
that's her
her language for for the editor editor
sucks by leaving the finger
maybe they're trying to preserve the
noise and they're like well this is
subtle enough
for people not to pick up on it but
people are picking up on it and now
they're
they're speculating that she's cheating
on the mukbangs and she's also not
uh new to controversy she actually uh
got went just finished through another
controversy of her uh
secretly doing sponsored videos and i
actually don't know how you get away
with that oh that's a huge thing in
korea right now that's it
what's that what's that um that a lot of
people on youtube are getting canceled
because what they're doing is
they're like really big celebrity people
that are going onto youtube or social
media and then they're saying like
oh my gosh i love this product so much
like i bought this with my own money
like
myself i bought this and i can tell you
right now i absolutely love
this product this video is not even
brought to you by but
honestly i just want to let you know
that this brand
is so delicious it has so it's like yeah
and then it's like that and then they're
like they're not even like
i i'm telling you i bought this with my
own money they're not
i'm not even working with this brand but
it's like deliberate explicit lying
yeah explicitly this is not an ad i just
love this product so much
yeah www dot like that and then use my
code
yeah i just want to support this product
called joombi it's really delicious
there's two locations one in roland
heights and one in westwood
uh you know and it's really delicious i
have no association to this brand at all
that is an example of blatantly lying i
don't have association to the brand but
i actually enjoy this
you're a friend oh oh that's okay but
that's like
two degrees of assist right that's it is
still an association counts i guess
i don't know but yeah so because of that
so then that that was like a huge
controversy with this one particular
actress
thank you that i i saw anybody but then
that
ended up trickling down to all of like
korean youtube
youtubers no it's not that they started
copying is that now
just even um even when they were saying
that they were sponsored like people are
getting cancelled like it's just
apparently it's a really big thing out
there right you have ftc rules out there
like you know how over here we you have
to have the ftc because of fire festival
yeah exactly yeah well they need they
haven't had their fire fest over there
yet well i think now
oh this is different this whole thing or
whatever the one that i was telling you
talking about yeah so how does like a a
mukbang star get cancelled
and what's the big deal with the whole
like cheating with the food thing
i don't know i don't understand but
accordingly
it seems like people have this idea that
if
for every finger that goes up there's an
edit and maybe they're saying she spits
out food is it like the next
highest following cheating that's
cheating who's getting hurt by it
the second best mukbang person right
maybe it's a mukbang culture
like that it's just you're supposed to
don't be faking that
like eat it all and become fat yeah like
the other ones like the three million
follower mukbang people they're like
super fat right yeah just like their
lives are being physically ruined even
though they're getting fame and then
they're looking at this person like whoa
oh do they actually gain weight how are
i'm just saying hypothetically yeah
but like why would you get mad at
something for spitting out the food then
because i mean that's better than having
like anorexia or not anorexia bulimia
like we actually throw up the food
afterwards
which i did hear like some mukbangers do
that i don't know
true but i think it seems like it's like
one of those purest
ideas right you know it's like every art
form every it's like you're lying to us
yeah every culture has like their this
is the proper way to do it like
forefathers or whatever have to set up
the foundation like the og of the
culture right so like who's like
the og of the mukbang culture that sets
this yeah they're supposed to go
oh you're supposed to edit it out it's
disgusting you don't want to spit it out
like that true
there's like a mukbang shaman who walks
down it's like no no no no no
i did no no no no no no wait what would
be like the dance equivalent
because i guess like for singing maybe
it's like lip syncing that that's
the dance equivalent is like stealing
people's choreography it's like doing
somebody else's choreography or a
combination sequence of moves and
calling it your own
that that is like cheating no i think
the equivalent might be
um like you it cuts close when you're
supposed to be doing like a
like the actual dance like my head stays
here and then somebody else's body goes
right here like a body double
it's like your face and then the feet
like you're not really doing it that's a
body double
yeah oh i see oh cause that's what
they're saying right there you're not
really eating it
right yeah it's like uh it's like uh
you're when you're doing a fight scene
and
uh if you can do through the entire
fight scene in a wide shot yeah that's
when it counts you're doing the falls
like jackets
[ __ ] art but then if you cut clothes
the camera's all shaking someone else
like all american fight scenes all
american fights so so this would be like
a stunt and this person is using a stunt
double but it's just like not cool
because like they got famous for the
stuff that's what it sounds
not supposed to be doing it's like
finding out jackie chan had a stun
double
yeah and you're like what i thought you
do your own stunts tom cruise yeah
it's kind of like when you see a porn
scene
it says girl swallows and you find out
that she didn't swallow she just
they pretended i should spit it out she
went like this just spit it out
no no no see that's not a real swallow
scene
true but that would have to be like the
headline of the mukbang be like swallows
everything
right but maybe that's like the culture
like you got it
you know yeah you just assumed that
swallowing is like part of part of it
yeah the fact that there's a spit bucket
is just like blasphemy
yeah that you know from a uh
asmr standpoint i feel like the spitting
sound might be interesting too
[Music]
i'm just like yeah you could enjoy that
you just might as well leave it in
or you could put like a mic where the
bucket is when the food lands like
there we go mine is yeah might as well
be like a secondary like mukbang
channel that's like out like one's in
i'd be down for that
to do that like just chew it and then
spit it out and it's like all about the
sounds and the little baby birds are in
the bucket they're like
oh [ __ ] oh i thought you guys were
talking about like coming out the back
end
oh so you eat right four hours later you
do a [ __ ] bong
and then you have [ __ ] yeah you have a
microphone and like
is the microphone on you on you on the
mouth or both you need two mics you need
two mics
but it's in the bucket it's a shot third
one here in your guts too when you
hear like your freaking intention
i have a theory with the whole asmr
thing because you know how everyone
needs to like calm the [ __ ] down
yeah i it's like what if it's like
sensory
underload because you know there's also
there's like sensory overload right i
get that where you're just like there's
too much
chaos i just need to hear a girl [ __ ]
eat some food right
like i need to hear lip smacking i need
somebody to just rub a microphone and
[ __ ] so you could just focus on one
room noise kind of like white noise kind
of thing right but also when you're in
nature
because i was recently in a nature right
there's so much
natural ambiance that is stimulating oh
yeah
cricket [ __ ] things birds whatever
wind
whatever there's just things moving yeah
it's nice
but when you're in a sterile room like
inside your house
it's completely silent there's nothing
that's weird silence hurts my ear
does that happen anywhere it gets loud
yeah it kind of gets loud and it does
get loud and it hurts the ring
the ringing is weird does anybody know
the science of the ring i do not i'm
asking
oh when it goes i thought it's because
you're losing yeah you lose
yeah that's right [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
lose that frequency
so for every time we're in pure silence
we're losing
hearing yeah well you're talking about a
constant ringing
yeah she's talking about when you're
losing like a follicle yes
like that yeah like that that frequency
is done for
you can't hear it anymore that's why the
older you get the less hearing
like you can't hear the same frequencies
as a child can huh
yep that's when you know when you're
when you go
that's my dad every every asian dad
already nice
very good i try to explain some [ __ ] to
my dad for like 30 minutes and he's like
mm-hmm
and now i'm like why didn't you just
stop me in the beginning
he just sees your lips moving he's like
i'll catch on
i'll catch on there's like no i didn't
catch on god damn
and it's like 30 minutes story or
something just using the frequency
analogy to his example
he's just oh i'm getting older but
really he's like huh even though he
hears you clearly
i would use that to my advantage that
seems very practical in the older ages
right
when you don't want to talk anymore not
pretend but just like yeah like
huh we don't even talk to each other
anymore
huh
[Music]
you